those are not companies gap old navy
duane reade they've had various success
Joe trying to get close to luxury can
Apple get actually be a luxury brand is
it just need to be near them what my
first response would be apple in its
category is near luxury or affordable
luxury simply by the way it invest in
design the user interface so this is
this is a stretch for them but not a far
reach in my view Paul what do you think
I mean this has been this was you need
to read back there Walter Isaacson's
biography of Steve Jobs and this was
something that he talked about the jobs
but Isaacson but jobs talked about a lot
the idea that he didn't think about
companies like Dell and Microsoft in
terms of the way he wanted to position
the company he thought about BMW and
Mercedes he thought about these kinds of
you know aspirational luxury or near
luxury products they could command a
price premium and you know had the kind
of margins that went with that and
that's the way he'd always thought of it
become so in a sense you know near
luxuries the way you know that the jobs
Ian Apple has always thought of itself
so how do you keep that going I mean how
do you keep it from doing something like
you know we've seen a number of brands
number of high retail brand sort of just
lose their luster when they get a pen
think of Perry Ellis or somethin
somethin just over soul their name to
everybody they could make it so it
became kind of meaningless and cheap
mm-hmm that will be their challenge if
you if you think about luxury it's two
components its exclusivity and its
experience on the experience side
they're going to have to improve and
they've announced that they will make
changes to their store experience you
know luxury sales don't typically take
place on hard surfaces they're on carpet
you know there's an intimacy to it
there's a service level that even would
be beyond apple today as good as they
are in the service experience end of
things with their training and hiring on
the exclusivity side that's where I
think it would be somewhat of a shift we
may see creative collaborations in the
future with designers we may see
customization to a greater degree that
they have done and and we're certainly
going to see them if they play it well
start to limit the availability of
certain design
and and that really these are hallmarks
of luxury brand development and
retailing and so Apple will have to
learn its way into that space although
you know given what they have done and
to the point made earlier jobs
philosophy I think this is well within
their grasp yeah Paul Kuharsky when I
think about limited editions I think
about inventory risk going back to the
future the technology of Technology
period should we not be thinking of it
that way we should be thinking about is
very limited runs that that are all
about i dint of establishing brand as
opposed to selling stuff i just have to
believe that we're all kind of wrong
about the luxury end of this that this
is going to be a very very small and
tangential part of the Apple watch
business because it just seems so
antithetical to the culture of the
company the near luxury part I get but
this scarcity an exclusivity part where
we start pricing for these incredible
price premiums and start building around
scarcity exclusivity that's just so imma
thet achill to the note of the company
itself and sort of the DNA of what Apple
always wanted to be they were the
opposite of IBM they wanted to be out
there and providing these products to
the rest of us and you know in a sense
exclusivity you know really wasn't part
of the selling message at all so you
know I get that they'll probably do some
side projects whether you know they're
working with you know other affiliates
others to do this kind of stuff but to
make it core to the product the risks
are from inventory to branding tool
inability to pull off exclusivity I
would be really surprised if it's a big
part of the pitch Joe Jacqueline is a
biggest risk yeah go ahead well I was
just going to build on that point and
say you're a hundred percent right and
that you know designed for all its
boring boring a target phrase but you
know this notion that everyone can
experience something better and have an
appreciation for design and
functionality user interface of a
different kinds of apples done that I
think it's just that can they make that
shift to playing a game where you know
this is these are things these are
objects that are desired in a way that
is different than say Mass or masti to
use that expression but I love the idea
that maybe this is the mission to make
you know what might otherwise be seen as
luxurious available to more and more
people while still sort of
coming off as genuine to the brand